foreign
[Music]
movie night guys oh whoa what Will's
getting a divorce so call him we clearly
haven't spoken to each other in years
call him that's what friends do
hey
how are you how was the beer business
I'm actually the brewmaster at my own
bar now congratulations you still got
that uh family of yours you wanna see a
photo
wow there they are cool
what are you up to
so much no brunch no I don't have time
for this can't be friends with a girl
there's lots of famous men and women
friends Laura Dern and Sam Neal in
Jurassic Park
[Applause]
our friendship
[Music]
with a couple of teenage girls your
whole thing is so weird and destructive
except we were distracted no we're
exactly the opposite we are constructed
I don't like killing like the second
most important man in your life
it's embarrassing being a mess in front
of you and Will's a much bigger mess
than I am
[Music]
not happy yeah I am happy I've never
been happier in my life
send me the invoice
break out of your box do a little nose
candy with us did they have CK back in
the day just like a mile horse
tranquilizer it's a horse track
s
[Music]
in my defense I thought it was cocaine
and just so I'm clear that's your
defense
the defense rests
[Applause]
[Music]